[Music]
peace be with you
welcome to the dean show we have an
exciting show we have a lot to talk
about a lot of ground to cover today
you heard about the chapel shooting also
recently
just the other day you had the muslim
who was driving his kids
from school and a man just came out
point blank
and killed him you hearing about that on
the news well that's something that's
happening you have the hijabi sister
also who was actually told imagine if
jesus's mother
mary who wears the hijab if she went to
a court now and she was told take that
thing off of your head
and that's what she was told now now
we're also going to be talking about
you know 24-hour coverage isis but none
of these things really that
we had mentioned that are these these
tragedies you don't get much media
coverage we're going to be talking about
all of this and more with my next guest
here on the dean show
don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is
how are you great to have you back on
the show yes how are you doing how you
been thank god
everything is good it's always a
pleasure to see you you're looking good
mashallah
life rough and tough and you know we're
going through some of the challenges
especially nowadays you have
a lot of misinformation out there about
islam we're going to get right into it
i'm going to i had mentioned some of the
tragic events that had happened
against innocent civilians these are
these are we consider you know terrorist
attacks the media is covering it
you know very um meniscusly they're
really not giving it the due
proper attention but it seems like
there's this group out there
uh was it uh isil isis and it seems like
24
7 you know the the american public is
being the world is being brainwashed
like
these people represent islam now i'm
going to share a quote with you
from a karim jabar he's a six-time nba
champion now what he did was he gave a
beautiful analogy he said when the kk
ku klux klan was burning crosses in
black families yards
prominent christians aren't required to
explain how these aren't really
christian acts
most people already realize that the kkk
doesn't represent christian teachings
you get the example he's making
exactly that's i think that sums it up
you know that
makes it simple and this is the way it
is with us
now that you know
an organization was created allah knows
best how it was created
and it is now utilized
uh to simply spread
um misinformation about our religion
and the capitalization is
minimizing or diminishing our religious
rights or our rights i i'm not
aware of you heard of
i guess in your intro you mentioned you
referred to maryam alaihissalam
being asked to take her hijab the mother
of jesus
yes who we love and revere absolutely
and and this happened actually in canada
i i wasn't sure if you were referring to
that event
yes i'm actually that's actually now
yeah a sister imagine a sister in a
courtroom
in in canada was asked by a female judge
a female judge i think it's a province
called quebec
in canada to remove her hijab and she
actually refused to reside on the case
until she
goes and and investigates
the fact whether she's entitled to
request the removal of the hijab
or not that sister may
reward her she made a beautiful
statement when she said
listen when i applied for my immigration
to the united st
to the canada i was wearing my hijab
when i received my citizenship
i was wearing the hijab and now i'm just
you know pursuing one of my rights so
again we go back to the issue is
an organization was created i don't know
who did it
how it was done and it is now
utilized um
you know like you you mentioned 24 7
almost coverage
uh and in the news to simply take away
our rights or brainstorm americans again
and and and spread islamophobia and and
we are out there have to do something
about it and we can just wait until it
comes to us
that's um that's what the dean's show is
all about educating sharing because we
care we want to get the facts out
now just to bring this point home i want
to make a comparison
because again we're not going to get
into you know there's a lot of
theories if you know these uh we're not
going to talk about if these are false
flag operations we're not going to talk
about
if you know this is this is a setup or
whatever the case let's assume that this
this you know
uh whatever they're saying that this
group is really
um out there and whatnot now the cia
and other organizations who have tried
to sum up how many
actually cons consist in this group and
they've come up numbers between 20
to 31 000 okay so there were some
interesting statistics
now if you have 1.6 billion muslims
those who submit to the will of the
creator okay
thy will be done is in the lord's prayer
that's islam isn't it so now that equals
1.6
billion to 1.7 billion human beings one
out every four human beings is a muslim
so if you take the higher number 35 31
000 that are in this this
small group that would equal point zero
zero one nine percent
this is the funny part right now let's
take this what i'm not done there this
is interesting now the kkk when the
1920s
they were at their peak so at that time
there were five
million of them in this organization
okay
and at that time in 1920s you had about
106
million people in the united states that
equals
4.7 percent 4.7
of of uh people in that country were a
part of the kkk
and they were uh screaming out jesus
saves they were wearing crosses
right but now did all of christians have
to come on and apologize for this what
are you what are your what's your take
on this
i think the blind that death
would see that there is inequality
in addressing issues once it comes to
muslims
vis-a-vis non-muslims there is no
question about it
and i think it's so naive for us to
still assume that justice
is going to take place because
all these are simply orchestrated
by hidden forces allah knows them so
i think what we need to worry about
eddie is
what can we do like i said
we have to be proactive we have to
engage
with the community in north america in
general
we have to increase our you know efforts
to
provide awareness to correct
misconceptions
we have to come out of the shill and
and this is simply the work of dawah
um you know worrying too much
about what is being done and and
and crying over the uh
the injustice of of handling
our cases vis-a-vis their cases
is not going to help us at all but what
we need to do and focus on on what will
help
us and we need to engage in dawah and
our simply is letting people
know who we are for the past 20 30 40
years
when really islam became
you know noticed in north america until
this very day
um very few efforts are placed
uh in media uh we can tell that
media is brainstorming is directing the
uh the general public in the united
states we need to start thinking about
media outlets where we can actually
uh uh you know get our message out to
to the people in that scale
beside the efforts in you know
so-called interfaith so we got to share
absolutely we got to get out there and
share and really show
this beautiful way of life for what
really what it is not what the media is
trying to portray right we're going to
take a break we'll be right back with
more here on the dean's show
islamic terrorism misconception
muslims are terrorists
[Music]
this is by far the biggest misconception
of islam given
unfairly by stereotyping in the public
image that the media gives
has anyone else noticed how when a
specific group of people attack another
group of people it is labeled as a hate
crime
but when a muslim opens fire on anybody
it is quickly regarded as terrorism
many political dictators and officials
or extremist groups
use the name of islam as a strategy to
garner followers and attention
when many of their practices go against
the true basis of islam
the media has also portrayed islam as a
cult or club
where if you join you become a terrorist
and that is now part of your agenda
however all over the world people
practice islam in the true form and use
it as a way of life
there are many verses in the quran that
go against the idea of terrorism
some of these verses include fight the
way of allah those that fight you
but do not transgress limits for god
does not love transgressors
this basically means do not fight except
in self-defense
and even in doing so do not go beyond
defense another verse states
if they seek peace then you seek peace
which means do not attack people for no
reason or kill innocent people
there is nowhere in islam whether it be
in the quran or the teachings of
muhammad that promotes the killing of
innocent people
please subscribe to the d show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation
in the link below
[Music]
back here on the dean show again
i'm gonna make a comparison a contrast
now
the kkk obviously doesn't represent
mainstream christianity
right and obviously if if you had the
media
constantly focusing on groups like that
most people would get brainwashed into
believing that and that's what they're
doing with islam and muslims and any
sincere people can pro
most likely see through that what about
this other group there's another group
out there i'm going to
go ahead and this is another christian
group and i'm going to
because seeing is believing so let me
show this video and then we'll get your
thoughts on this
not well she's got a chance of of
becoming and
growing more but i don't think she will
ever
get out from tibito somebody
you may not have heard of her but
recently santa muerte began making
international headlines
amid reports of ritual human sacrifice
just south of the u.s border in mexico
and as 8 news investigative reporter aj
lego uncovers the worship of death
is being practiced right here in the
metro area this sket little maiden
with the empty eyes is a saint for
sinners
and her popularity is exploding she has
millions of followers
devotees both in the u.s and in mexico
and many of those devotees are among the
most violent criminals in the world
she is the premier narco saint so what
we just saw was saint
muerta she's the saint of death and
christians
actually worship her and that and then
she's gaining popularity and into the
millions
and many of the the drug cartel
who are decapitating you know who are
doing some of the most
notorious terrorist acts now they
actually
find justification in doing that because
they fall back on saint death
who they link back to christianity and
then you also have some of these leaders
as you see in many different articles
some of these cartel leaders
who are actually christian and they will
go ahead one of them
particularly um zero monero he actually
wrote a 104 page booklet
talking about christian life and
christian living right
so now my point is shake and you tell me
what you think now
imagine if the media was highlighting
this part this group as if they
represented christianity as they do with
this other group saying that they
represented snob to isil
what what is your thoughts on that they
will still misinform
the non-muslims because we as muslims
know exactly what the teachings of jesus
were
and they are almost if not 100 percent
uh identical to our teachings tawheed
monotheism
the worship of one god and simply
morality is
observed so they will not misinform
muslims
they will definitely affect the minds
the brains the hearts the souls of
christians
because i have to tell you something
that
the average layman in the united states
or
in canada they are not even educated
about their own religion
and but yeah i agree if this message is
uh simply focused uh upon
like isis the way that they are handling
isis
you would think that every christian
would believe that and
this is again misinformation having
prominent scholars come out i mean these
are
the top scholars that the average muslim
look up to
and they've condemned these acts of of
of
um torture that have been done the
beheading of aid workers you know the
burning i mean
uh of the jordanian pilot let me put it
this way
to be fair to everybody if isis
the way that the media portrays them
this is certainly the ideology of
accepting islam called the breakaways
if again so you don't misquote me if
because quite frankly i mistrust the
media i don't believe the media and
every muslim and non-muslim got to be
very careful
with the message they hear on especially
these
mainstream media outlets they are
orchestrated they
they they come out in a very uh
organized manner listen media eddie is
the new sorcery
you know we read the story of the boy of
the and the king and and the sunnah
we read the story of the phiro and moses
they these rulers or these
governments at that time they actually
relied on
actual uh sorcerers
people who actually come and affect the
eyes the the way that you see the
deception
media right now is sorcery sorcery is
media
so you got to be careful what you watch
and what message you're you're hearing
and you know if you have iman inshallah
allah will
let you see the truth tobacco what
you're saying actually they they have
organizations who are measured the
amount of
truth may have truths and i mean
deliberate lies
that these media most of them that they
put out and actually the
biggest thing was when the um media was
saying that there were these no-go
zones in france and other places and
these was a blatant line birmingham is
uh
100 or 90 muslims these are lies i went
to birmingham
you know you still see christians there
but it's clear
it's clear killing aid workers killing
civilians all of these things burning
this is this has nothing to do with
islam absolutely
absolutely you know i you know i that
jordanian pilot um
i myself you know you know we we're
heads of communities i you know you have
to come up with something to explain to
the people what's going on
uh because and this is really should be
the duty of imams and religious heads in
in their
own little communities simply there are
three
hadith in in sunnah
where the prophet sallallahu alaihi made
it crystal clear
that the only one who is entitled to
punish using
fire is the lord of the fire and
actually
during the time of alibn abi talib
certain individuals actually claim that
he's got
and he simply burned
and you know he asked that's his
humility and humbleness
in a way we that is totally um you know
uh something that we shouldn't even uh
a recent scholar bin baz
he said even you know capital punishment
using electricity could be actually
a branch of fire so we should not even
do it so that would be uh
against islam as well so islam is
crystal clear on these issues
these practices and and these behaviors
are not condoned by islam at all i
understand there is a little view out
there
if if this is casas in a way if the
person have burned
uh you know the then he's to be burned
there is a
but this is not the view of the majority
of the jurist
on the subject in a way eddie
we need to pay attention here to to the
challenge that we're facing
as muslims um there
is somehow a wave of islamophobia
very similar to the one that we
experienced
right after 9 11 in order to execute
some maybe war here and there that's
what i'm reading myself
there is a setup and again you know i i
i don't believe so much in that
you know conspiracy theory but uh i
experienced 9 11 and i'm sure you did
and i'm sure a lot of our viewers did
that uh you know islamophobia was used
to justify
war here and there and and and they did
execute it
it looks like something similar is about
to happen
now we as muslims living in the united
states and canada
are on the front line and again i go
back to the main point
let's be proactive let's go out there
and reach out and let people know who we
are
because it's coming to us we got to go
and bring it to them
but in a peaceful nice
that's right that's what islam is
propagating peace and love
yes loving for humanity what you love
for yourself right we want the best for
all amen
mankind so we're going to take a break
and we'll come back you mentioned 9 11
obviously islam has nothing to do with
any of these terrorist acts but
we have some family members i think many
people don't know about this
that we're going to take a clip here and
they can watch it while we take a break
and architects and engineers who
actually are educating people on this
event we'll be right back with more here
on the d show
and what caught my eye as more than 300
architects and
engineers examined the evidence about
building seven's collapse
and disagree with the official report
issued by the national
institute of standards and technology i
certainly am much more open-minded about
it than i was
and it is because of the involvement of
the 911 families and all these engineers
and architects
you are about to hear from architect of
23 years
richard gage aia member of the american
institute of architects and founder of
architects and engineers
for 9 11 truth now there are more than
1500
architects and engineers who say that it
could not have been
brought down by office fires
they are backed by 9 11 family members
who are calling for an independent
unbiased
investigation i'm a family member trying
to find out the answers
to the murder of three thousand plus
people
the bottom line is that it needs to be
investigated
properly
please look at architects and engineers
people
all around the world scientists all
around the world
are questioning this and there's some
deep deep explaining to do
it took some kind of consciousness
raising on my part before i was willing
to
look at the the possibilities and really
you need to go
where the evidence leads as an engineer
i have three degrees in
engineering i signed that petition for
architects and engineers
for 9 11 truth some time ago because the
american people
absolutely need the truth of 9 11.
look at the evidence in fact i'll say
this very categorically
any reasonable person who looks at the
evidence that's been brought
forward has got to come away with the
feeling
that something has to be done a real
investigation has to be put forward
we will never heal this country will
never ever
ever forget that day we have to demand
a new investigation i want justice here
back here on the dean show now i
mentioned we also we were going to talk
about surely it's it's so sad when any
innocent human being dies
and you see that as soon as a submitter
to god a muslim jesus was a muslim
abraham moses they all did god's will
that's what a muslim is
white black chinese italian german you
know so many islam is the fastest
growing way of life
in the world because it just makes sense
you know it doesn't call to terrorism it
calls
a human being to have peace with their
creator peace with themselves and peace
with society and humanity
and when you see these muslims in chapel
hill who died this
um also a brother who just got killed
the other day and then the media they
don't label this a terrorist ass a hate
crime it's
parking ticket road rage what do you
think about this
it's again the inequality uh against
muslims
um you know recently we we purchased
as an organization in denver a
non-profit
a building that we want to make as a
community center
uh darth vader organization that i'm
heading i'm just giving an example
and and then we're in colorado and as
soon as we actually had the property
under contract
uh the home owner association started
actually approaching us
and asking us all type of questions what
are you going to do this what what is
this for and what is this for and what
is this for
you know we responded with one simple
question
if we were to happen to be a christian
organization
would you have asked these questions
you take this you know look at the media
coverage of the three
students may allah have mercy on their
soul
and grant their parents and family
members steadfastness
look at the media coverage and and has
it been for
you know us complaining about it they
probably would have
received zero coverage um
this is where um stressing the
importance
of having our own media outlets
in the uh in north america
and you know and i'm glad the dean show
does contribute to this greatly
but we need something that is 24 7 like
they do and and this is the solution we
gotta
you know try to solve our own issues
but at the same time eddie i want the
viewers
to also realize that this life
for believers is a testing place
not a resting place allah told us this
that listen if you will practice your
deen
if you will stick to monotheism and you
you strive to live your lives
according to the way of allah subhana wa
you will be tested the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
when he was asked who will be tested
most by saddam
he said the prophets the messengers then
the righteous
then those who are closest to them once
it comes to quality of
of religion look at this look the
statement that he made
and every believer will be tested in
accordance
with the quality of his deen
if his if the quality of his iman faith
is high
then his test will be elevated allah
told us in the quran
you shall be tested
with respect to your wealth and your own
selves
and you shall hear from those who
associate and worship other deities with
allah subhana wa a lot of harmful things
now what should we do what should we do
patience perseverance and
that should be our attitude when we go
through these calamities
uh go through these tests go through
these hardships
and and trials this is the active this
is where iman
is faith believing is an asset
in the life of a believer because it
helped them overcome
these injustices these
obvious inequality
in the society in dealing with our
issues
but this i want to stress this i want to
stress upon this eddie
this does not entitle us to react in a
violent way
or to respond in a mean way no
we should be patient we should be
forbidding
and dealing with these individuals
because this was the manner and the
character of rasulullah
before we leave we're out of time to the
family members we also
forgot to mention um and these incidents
are
on the rise you also had a another
brother i lived in canada
the man actually came and shot him
through the people
killed him right it's another hate crime
now for the parents who've lost these
loved ones these were these were
individuals who were out there
making humanity a better place they were
doing good
uh dedicating like the dentist getting
dedicating their time and their services
for charity and for organizations of
helping humanity now their parents are
left
without their children um i want to tell
you something eddie
and and those who listen and watch my my
buzz and talks i have said this in
reaction to this i was actually happy to
be in edmonton
alberta canada masjid rashid they're
giving a khutbah and i said if you
actually
look into the quran and the sunnah
to figure out the greatest calamity
that a person may be inflicted with it's
actually losing
your child because there is a line there
that the scholars say
the greater the the calamity the greater
the reward
or seizes or ordains the death
of a loved one of your child allah will
send the angels
to the parents and allah knows we
believe that allah knows everything
and then the angels will go back to
allah subhanahu wa
and allah will ask them what is my
servant is saying
they will say o allah they are saying
they are saying or he is saying or she
is saying alhamdulillah
you know what allah would say
build for my servant a house in jannah
and call it the house of praise the
house of alhamd
why because of the calamity you know
it's so amazing one of the scholars of
hadith i want to share this with you
his name is sofiane thori he's
he's expert of hadith look at this now
the amount of text that he read in the
sunnah regarding the reward that a
person
receives if he loses his child
himself wished that his he thought that
the idea occurred to him
that his son would die and he will get
that reward so his son was
i mean the thought occurred he thought
about it that the son
his son his name is abdullah was walking
in front of him
and he actually looked at him he was
reading that text he said
my son you die and i get your reward i
get that reward
if calamity have you got hit by
something yeah he got sick or anything
yeah i mean
he did not make dua the thought occurred
to him gives relief
to the parents now knowing that god
almighty is the most just he's going to
reward you
so in energy i want to say that you know
patience and your reward will be
with allah subhanahu
you know i want to tell this to to the
parents of of the three students or
any brother or sister who lost
love once i want to share with you
hadith
the hadith is authentic
a companion of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi used to sit with the prophet
and he used to bring with him his little
son his little child
and you know a father and a son
relationship is is very touchy and
notice this so he asked the companion
this question
do you love your child you know what the
companion said to the prophet salla
he said
may allah love you as much as i love my
son
subhanallah days later the prophet
sallallahu alaihi sallam did not see his
son
i did not see this companion so he sent
for him
so the messenger came back to the
prophet salallahu telling him
her son passed away that is why he is
going through the
you know the the period of of grief
so when rasool allah asked for him to
come
he asked him this question wouldn't you
like
any time that you want to enter from any
of the gates of jannah
into jannah your son is ahead of you to
take your hand in
wouldn't you are you contented that your
son will take your hand into
any of the gate eight gates of jannah he
says
has ordained to take back and
we have to be patient and may allah
gather you all in jannah
with your loved one thank you i mean we
started with peace we end with peace
thank you so much and we've learned some
very
great things here on the dean show today
about sharing
because we we sincerely care about
humanity and we want the best for all of
mankind
we also learned from the beginning look
there is a europol
statistic poll that now less than two
percent of terrorist attacks have been
committed by muslims in europe and the
u.s
and we compared the kkk christian
organization
and some of these drug cartel
organizations who don't represent
christianity and we know that as muslims
but now you
who's tuning in and you sincerely want
to know about islam maybe you're a
politician now you want to get your
facts straight
and now you're getting it straight here
on the dean show that these barbaric
acts
don't represent islam it doesn't
represent the muslims
and what islam is about is something
that
is fascinating because more people are
coming to islam than any other religion
is the fastest growing way of life
because it it just makes sense worship
the creator not the creation do good
deeds
make a positive effect on society yes
continue to watch our shows
to learn more we send our our
condolences to all those innocent people
who have lost their
their loved ones be patient and remember
the house of praise that's built
as the sheikh had eloquently given us
that hadith
of the person who is patient with the
tests of allah
and allah building a house of praise for
that person who've lost that loved one
continue to watch us here on the d show
every week
subscribe if you haven't already and
we'll see you next time until then peace
be with you
please subscribe to the d show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below